PROFESSOR: So we spent the
last few lectures discussing
Szemerédi's regularity lemma.
So we saw that this
is an important tool
with important
applications, allowing
you to do things like a proof
of Roth's theorem via graph
theory.
One of the concepts that came
up when we were discussing
the statement of Szemerédi's
regularity lemma is that
of pseudorandomness.
So the statement of Szemerédi's
graph regularity lemma is that
you can partition an arbitrary
graph into a bounded number
of pieces so that the
graph looks random-like,
as we called it, between
most pairs of parts.
So what does random-like mean?
So that's something that I want
to discuss for the next couple
of lectures.
And this is the idea
of pseudorandomness,
which is a concept
that is really
prevalent in combinatorics, in
theoretical computer science,
and in many different areas.
And what pseudorandomness tries
to capture is, in what ways
can a non-random
object look random?
So before diving into
some specific mathematics,
I want to offer some
philosophical remarks.
So you might know
that, on a computer,
you want to generate
a random number.
Well, you type in a "rand," and
it gives you a random number.
But of course, that's not
necessarily true randomness.
It came from some
pseudorandom generator.
Probably there's some seed and
some complex-looking function
and outputs something
that you couldn't
distinguish from random.
But it might not actually
be random but just something
that looks, in many
different ways, like random.
So there is this
concept of random.
You can think about
a random graph,
right, generate this
Erdos-Renyi random graph.
Every edge occurs independently
with some probability.
But I can also show you some
graph, some specific graph,
which I say, well, it's, for
all intents and purposes,
just as good as a random graph.
So in what ways can we
capture that concept?
So that's what I
want to discuss.
And that's the topic
of pseudorandomness.
And of course, well,
this idea extends
to many areas, number
theory and whatnot,
but we'll stick
with graph theory.
In particular, I want to explore
today just one specific notion
of pseudorandomness.
And this comes from an important
paper called "Quasi-random
graphs."
And this concept is due to
Chung, Graham, and Wilson
back in the late '80s.
So they defined various
notions of pseudorandomness,
and I want to state them.
And what it turns out--
and the surprising part
is that these notions,
these definitions,
although they look
superficially different,
they are actually all
equivalent to each other.
So let's see what
the theorem says.
So the set-up of this theorem
is that you have some fixed
real p between 0 and 1.
And this is going to be
your graph edge density.
So for any sequence
of graphs, Gn--
so from now, I'm going
to drop the subscript n,
so G will just be Gn--
such that the
number of vertices--
so G is n vertex with
edge density basically p.
So this is your
sequence of graphs.
And the claim is that
we're going to state
some set of properties.
And these properties
are all going
to be equivalent to each other.
So all of these properties
capture some notion
of pseudorandomness, so in what
ways this is graph G or really
a sequence of graphs.
Or you can talk about
a specific graph
and have some error
parameters and error balance.
They're all roughly
the same ideas.
So in what ways can we
talk about this graph G
being random-like?
Well, we already saw one
notion when we discussed
Szemerédi's regularity lemma.
And let's see that here.
So this notion is
known as discrepancy.
And it says that if I restrict
my graph to looking only
at edges between some
pair of vertex sets,
then the number of
edges should be roughly
what you would expect
based on density alone.
So this is basically
the notion that
came up in epsilon regularity.
This is essentially
the same as saying
that G is epsilon
regular with itself
where this epsilon now is hidden
in this little o parameter.
So that's one notion
of pseudorandomness.
So here's another notion
which is very similar.
So it's almost just a
semantic difference,
but, OK, so I have to
do a little bit of work.
So let me call this DISC prime.
So it says that if you look at
only edges within this set--
so instead of taking two
sets, I only look at one set--
and then look at
how many edges are
in there versus how many you
should expect based on density
alone, these two
numbers are also
very similar to each other.
So let's get to something that
looks dramatically different.
The next one, I'm
going to call count.
So count says that
for every graph
H, the number of labeled
copies of H in G--
OK, so labeled copies, I
mean that the vertices of H
are labeled.
So for every triangle, there
are six labeled triangles
that correspond to that
triangle in the graph.
The number of labeled
copies of H is--
so what should you expect if
this graph were truly random?
You would expect p raised
to the number of edges of H
plus small error times n raised
to number of vertices of H.
And just as a remark, this
little o term, little o 1 term,
may depend on H.
So this condition, count,
says for every graph H,
this is true.
And by that, I mean
for every H, there
is some sequence
of decaying errors.
But that sequence
of decaying errors
may depend on your graph H. OK.
The next one is almost
a special case of count.
It's called C4.
And it says that the number
of labeled copies of C4,
so the fourth cycle, is at
most p raised to power of 4--
so again, what you should
expect in a random setting just
for cycle count alone.
I see, already, some
of you are surprised.
So we'll discuss that this
is an important constraint.
It turns out that alone
implies everything, just having
the correct C4 count.
The next one, we
will call codegree.
And the codegree condition
says that if you look at a pair
of vertices and look at their
number of common neighbors--
in other words, their codegree--
then what should you
expect this quantity to be?
So there are n
vertices that possibly
could be common neighbors,
and each one of them,
if this were a random graph
with edge probability p,
then you expect the
number of common neighbors
to be around p squared n.
So the codegree condition
is that this sum is small.
So most pairs of vertices have
roughly the correct number
of common neighbors.
So codegree is number
Next, and the last one,
certainly not the least,
is eigenvalue condition.
So here, we are going to denote
by lambda 1 through lambda G
the eigenvalues of the
adjacency matrix of G.
So we saw this object
in the last lecture.
So I include multiplicities.
If some eigenvalue occurs
with multiple times,
I include it multiple times.
So the eigenvalue condition
says that the top eigenvalue
is around pn and that,
more importantly,
the other eigenvalues
are all quite small.
Now, for d regular graph,
the top eigenvalue--
and it's fine to think
about d regular graphs
if you want to get some
intuition out of this theorem.
For d regular graph,
the top eigenvalue
is equal to d, because
the top eigenvector is d.
It's the all-one vector.
So top eigenvector is all-one
vector, which has eigenvalue d.
And what the eigenvalue
condition says
is that all the other
eigenvalues are much smaller.
So here, I'm thinking of d
as on the same order as n.
OK, so this is the theorem.
So that's what we'll do today.
We'll prove that all
of these properties
are equivalent to each other.
And all of these
properties, you should
think of as characterizations
of pseudorandomness.
And of course, this
theorem guarantees us
that it doesn't matter
which one you use.
They're all equivalent
to each other.
And our proofs are
actually going to be--
I mean, I'm going to try to
do everything fairly slowly.
But none of these
proofs are difficult.
We're not going to use
any fancy tools like
Szemerédi's regularity lemma.
In particular, all of
these quantitative errors
are reasonably
dependent on each other.
So I've stated
this theorem so far
in this form where there
is a little 1 error.
But equivalently, so I can
equivalently state theorem as--
for example, have DISC with
an epsilon error, which
is that some inequality is
true with at most epsilon error
instead of little o.
And you have a different
epsilon for each one of them.
And the theorem,
it turns out that--
OK, so the proof of
this theorem will
be that these conditions
are true, so all equivalent,
up to at most a polynomial
change in the epsilons.
In other words, so
property one is true
for epsilon implies
that property two is
true for some epsilon
raised to a constant.
So the changes in parameters
are quite reasonable.
And we'll see this
from the proof,
but I won't say it
again explicitly.
Any questions so far about
the statement of this theorem?
So as I mentioned just now,
the most surprising part
of this theorem
and the one that I
want you to pay the
most attention to
is the C4 condition.
This seems, at
least at face value,
the weakest condition
among all of them.
It just says the
correct C4 count.
But it turns out to be
equivalent to everything else.
And there's something
special about C4, right?
If I replace C4 by C3, by just
triangles, then it is not true.
So I want you to think
about, where does C4
play this important role?
How does it play
this important role?
OK.
So let's get started
with a proof.
But before that, let me--
so in this proof,
one recurring theme
is that we're going to be using
the Cauchy-Schwarz inequality
many times.
And I want to just begin with
an exercise that gives you
some familiarity with applying
the Cauchy-Schwarz inequality.
And this is a simple tool,
but it's extremely powerful.
And it's worthwhile
to master how to use
a Cauchy-Schwarz inequality.
So let's get some practice.
And let me prove a claim
which is not directly related
to the proof of the
theorem, but it's
indirect in that it explains
somewhat the C4 condition
and why we have less than
or equal to over there.
So the lemma is that if
you have a graph on n
vertices such that the number
of edges is at least pn
squared over 2, so edge
density basically p, then
the number of labeled copies of
C4 is at least p to the 4 minus
little o 1 n to the 4th.
So if you have a graph
with each density p--
p's your constant--
then the number of C4s
is at least roughly what you
would expect in a random graph.
So let's see how to do this.
And I want to show
this inequality as a--
well, I'll show you how
to prove this inequality.
But I also want to draw a
sequence of pictures, at least,
to explain how I think
about applications
of the Cauchy-Schwarz
inequality.
OK.
So the first thing
is that we are
counting labeled copies of C4.
And this is basically but
not exactly the same as
number of homomorphic copies of
C4 and G. So by this guy here,
I really just mean you are
mapping vertices of C4 to G
so that the edges
all map to edges.
But we are allowing not
necessarily injective maps,
C4 to G. But that's OK.
So the number of non-injective
maps is at most cubic.
So we're not really
affecting our count.
So it's enough to think
about homomorphic copies.
OK.
So what's going on here?
So let me draw a
sequence of pictures
illustrating this calculation.
So first, we are thinking
about counting C4s.
So that's a C4.
I can rewrite the C4 count as a
sum over pairs of vertices of G
as the squared codegree.
And what happens
here-- so this is true.
I mean, it's not hard
to see why this is true.
But I want to draw
this in pictures,
because when you have
larger and bigger graphs,
it may be more difficult
to think about the algebra
unless you have
some visualization.
So what happens here is that
I notice that the C4 has
a certain reflection.
Namely, it has a reflection
along this horizontal line.
And so if I put these
two vertices as u and v,
then this reflection
tells you that you
can write this number
of homomorphic copies
as the sum of squares.
But once you have this
reflection-- and reflections
are super useful,
because they allow
us to get something
into a square
and then, right after, apply
the Cauchy-Schwarz inequality.
So we apply Cauchy-Schwarz here.
And we obtain that this
sum is at most where
I can pull the square out.
And I need to think about
what is the correct factor
to put out here.
And that should be--
so what's the correct factor
that I should put out there?
AUDIENCE: 1 over n squared.
PROFESSOR: OK, so
1 over n squared.
So I don't actually like doing
these kind of calculations
with sums, because then
you have to keep track
of these normalizing factors.
One of the upcoming chapters,
when we discuss graph limits--
or in fact, you
can even do this.
Instead of taking sums,
if you take an average,
if you take an expectation,
then it turns out
you never have to worry about
these normalizing factors.
So normalizing factors
should never bother you
if you do it correctly.
But just to make sure
things are correct, please
keep me in check.
All right.
So what happened in this step?
In this step, we
pulled out that square.
And pictorially, what
happens is that we got rid
of half of this picture.
So we used Cauchy-Schwarz,
and we wiped out
half of the picture.
And now what we can
do is, well, we're
counting these guys,
this path of length 2.
But I can reprioritize
this picture
so that it looks like that.
And now I notice that there
is one more reflection.
So there's one more reflection.
And that's the reflection
around the vertical axis.
So let me call
this top vertex x.
And I can rewrite
the sum like that.
OK.
So once more, we
do Cauchy-Schwarz,
which allows us to get rid
of half of the picture.
And now I'm going to
draw the picture first,
because then you see that
what we should be left with
is just a single edge.
And then you write
down the correct sum,
making sure that all the
parentheses and normalizations
are correct.
But somehow, that
doesn't worry me so much,
because I know this will
definitely work out.
But whatever it is, you're just
summing the number of edges.
So that's just the
number of edges.
And so we put everything in.
And we find that the final
quantity is at least p raised
to 4 n to 4.
So I did this quite slowly.
But I'm also emphasizing the
sequence of pictures, partly
to tell how I think
about these inequalities.
Because for other similar
looking inequalities-- in fact,
there is something called
Sidorenko's conjecture, which
I may discuss more in
a future lecture, that
says that this
kind of inequality
should be true
whenever you replace C4
by any bipartite graph.
And that's a major open
problem in combinatorics.
It's kind of hard to keep
track of these calculations
unless you have a visual anchor.
And this is my visual anchor,
which I'm trying to explain.
Of course, it's down to earth.
It's just the sequence
of inequalities.
And this is also some
practice with Cauchy-Schwarz.
All right.
Any questions?
But one thing that
this calculation
told us is that if you
have edge density p,
then you necessarily have C4
density at least p to the 4th.
So that partly explains why
you have at most, then, here.
So you always know that
it's at least this quantity.
So the C4 quasi
randomness condition
is really the equivalent
to replacing this less than
or equal to by an equal sign.
So let's get
started with proving
the Chung-Graham-Wilson theorem.
So the first place
that we'll look at
is the two versions of DISC.
So DISC stands for discrepancy.
So first, the fact that DISC
implies DISC prime, I mean,
this is pretty easy.
You take y to equal to x.
Be slightly careful about the
definitions, but you're OK.
So not much to do there.
The other direction,
where you only
have discrepancies
for a single set
and you want to
produce discrepancies
for pairs of sets--
so this is actually a fairly
common technique in algebra
that allows you to go
from bilinear forms
to quadratic forms
and vice versa.
It's that kind of calculation.
So let me do it here
concretely in this setting.
So here, what you
should think of
is that you have two sets, x
and y, and they might overlap.
And what they
correspond to in the--
when you think about the
corresponding Venn diagram,
where I'm looking at ways
that a pair of vertices
can fall in x and/or y--
so if you have x and y.
And so it's useful to keep
track of which vertices
are in which set.
But what the thing
finally comes down
to is that the number of edges
with one vertex in x and one
vertex in y, I can write this
bilinear form-type quantity
as an appropriate sum of just
number of edges in single sets.
And so there are several ways
to check that this is true.
One way is to just tally,
keep track of how many edges
are you counting in each step.
So if you are trying to count
the number of edges in--
yeah, so let's say if
you're trying to count
the number of edges in--
with one vertex in
x, one vertex in y.
Then what this corresponds
to is that count.
But let me do a reflection.
And then you see that
you can write this sum
as an alternating sum
of principal squares,
so this one big square plus the
middle square and minus the two
sides squares, which is
what that sum comes to.
All right.
So if we assume
DISC prime, then I
know that all of
these individual sets
have roughly the correct number
of edges up to a little o of n
squared error.
And again, I don't have to
do this calculation again,
because it's the
same calculation.
So the final thing should be
p times the sizes of x and y
together plus this same error.
So that shows you DISC
prime implies DISC.
So the self version
of discrepancy
implies the pair
version of discrepancy.
So let's move on to count.
To show that DISC
implies count--
actually, we already did this.
So this is the counting lemma.
So the counting
lemma tells us how
to count labeled copies if you
have these epsilon regularity
conditions, which is
exactly what DISC is.
So count is good.
Another easy implication
is count implies C4.
Well, this is actually
just tautological.
C4 condition is a special
case of the count hypothesis.
All right.
So let's move on to some
additional implications that
require a bit more work.
So what about C4
implies codegree?
So this is where we
need to do this kind
of Cauchy-Schwarz exercise.
So let's start with C4.
So assume a C4 condition.
And suppose you have this--
so I want to deduce that the
codegree condition is true.
But first, let's
think about just
what is the sum
of these codegrees
as I vary u and v over
all pairs of vertices.
So this is that picture.
So that is equal to the sums
of degrees squared, which now,
by Cauchy-Schwarz, you can
deduce to be at least n times 2
raised to number
of edges-- namely,
the sum of the degrees--
that thing squared.
So now we assume
the C4 condition--
actually, no, we assume that G
has the density as written up
there.
So this quantity is p
squared plus little 1 times
n cubed, which is
what you should expect
in a random graph of Gnp.
But that's not quite
what we're looking for.
So this is just the
sum of the codegrees.
What we actually
want is the deviation
of codegrees from its
expectations, so to speak.
Now, here's an
important technique
from probabilistic
combinatorics is
that if you want to control the
deviation of a random variable,
one thing you should
look at is the variance.
So if you can
control the variance,
then you can control
the deviation.
And this is a method known
as a second moment method.
And that's what we're
going to do here.
So what we'll try to show is
that the second moment of these
codegrees--
namely, the sum
of their squares--
is also what you should expect
as if the random setting.
And then you can put them
together to show what you want.
So this quantity here,
well, what is this?
We just saw-- see, up there,
it's also codegree squared.
So this quantity
is also the number
of labeled copies of C4--
not quite, because you
might have two vertices
and the same vertex.
So I incorporate a small error.
So it's a cubic error, but
it's certainly sub n to the 4.
And we assume that the number of
labeled copies of C4 by the C4
condition is no more than
basically p to the 4 times
n raised to power 4.
OK.
So now you have a first moment.
You have some average,
and you have some control.
In the second moment,
I can put them together
to bound the deviation
using this idea
of controlling variance.
So the codegree deviation
is upper bounded by--
so here, using
Cauchy-Schwarz, it's
upper bounded by basically
the same sum, except I
want to square the summand.
This also gets rid of
the pesky absolute value
side, which is not nicely,
algebraically behaved.
OK.
So now I have the square,
and I can expand the square.
So I expand the square
into these terms.
And the final term here
is p to the 4 n to the 6.
No, n to the 4.
All right.
But I have controlled
the individual terms
from the calculations above.
So I can upper bound
this expression
by what I'm writing down now.
And basically, you should
expect that everything
should cancel out,
because they do cancel out
in the random case.
Of course, the
sanity check, it's
important to write
down this calculation.
So if everything
works out right,
everything should cancel out.
And indeed, they do cancel out.
And you get that--
so this is a multiplication.
This is p squared.
Is that OK?
So everything should cancel out.
And you get a
little o of n cubed.
To summarize, in this
implication from C4
to codegree, what
we're doing is we're
controlling the
variance of codegrees
using the C4 condition and
the second moment bound,
showing that the
C4 condition trumps
over the codegree condition.
Any questions so far?
So I'll let you ponder
in this calculation.
The next one that we'll do
is codegree implies DISC.
And that will be a calculation
in a very similar flavor.
But it will be a slightly
longer but with similar flavor
of calculation.
So let me do that
after the break.
All right.
So what have we done so far?
So let's summarize the
chain of implications
that we have already proved.
So first, we
started with showing
that the two versions
of DISC are equivalent.
And then we also noticed
that DISC implies count
through the counting lemma.
So we also observed that count
implies C4 tautologically
and C4 implies codegree.
So the next natural thing to
do is to complete this circuit
and show that the
codegree condition implies
the discrepancy condition.
So that's what we'll do next.
And in some sense,
these two steps,
you should think of them as
going in this natural chain,
where C4--
so C4 is like this, C4.
Codegree condition
is really about that.
And DISC is really
about single edges.
So you can go from--
so double-- if you half,
you get much more power.
So it's going in
the right direction,
going downstream, so to speak.
So that's what we're doing
now, going downstream.
And then you go upstream
via the counting lemma.
All right.
Let's do codegree implies DISC.
So we want to show the
discrepancy condition, which
is one written up there.
But before that, let
me first show you
that the degrees do
not vary too much,
show that the degrees are
fairly well distributed,
which is what you should
expect in a pseudorandom graph.
So you don't expect the half
the vertices, half in degrees,
twice the other half.
So that's the first thing
I want to establish.
If you look at degrees, this
variance, this deviation,
is not too big.
OK.
So like before, we see
an absolute value sign.
We see a sum.
So we'll do Cauchy-Schwarz.
Cauchy-Schwarz allows us
to bound this quantity,
replacing the summand
by a sum of squared.
I have a square, so I
can expand the square.
So let me expand the square.
And I get that, so just
expanding this square inside.
And you see this degree
squared is that picture, so
that sum of codegrees.
And sum of the degrees is
just the number of edges.
But we now assume the
codegree condition,
which in particular implies
that the sum of the codegrees
is roughly what
you would expect.
So the sum of the
codegrees should
be p squared n cubed plus
a little o n cubed error
at the end.
Likewise, the number of
edges is, by assumption,
what you would expect
in a random graph.
And then the final term.
And like before-- and of
course, it's good to do a sanity
check--
everything should cancel out.
So what you end up with
is little o of n squared,
showing that the degrees
do not vary too much.
And once you have
that promise, then we
move onto the actual
discrepancy condition.
So this discrepancy
can be rewritten
as the sum over vertices
little x and big X, the degree
from little x to y minus
p times the size of y,
so rewriting the sum.
And of course, what
should we do next?
Cauchy-Schwarz.
Great.
So we'll do a Cauchy-Schwarz.
OK, so here's an important
step or trick, if you will.
So we'll do Cauchy-Schwarz.
And something very nice happens
when you do Cauchy-Schwarz
here.
OK.
So you can write
down the expression
that you obtain when
you do Cauchy-Schwarz.
So let me do that first.
OK.
So here's a step which is
very easy to gloss over.
But I want to pause and
emphasize this step,
because this is actually
really important.
What I'm going to do now is
to observe that the summand is
always non-negative.
Therefore, I can enlarge
the sum from just little x
and X to the entire vertex set.
And this is important, right?
So it's important that we
had to do Cauchy-Schwarz
first to get a
non-negative summand.
You couldn't do this
in the beginning.
So you do that.
And so I have this
sum of squares.
I expand.
I write out all
these expressions.
And now the little x range
over the entire vertex set.
All right.
So what was the
point of all of that?
So you see this expression
here, the degree
from little x to big Y
squared, what is that?
How can we rewrite
this expression?
So counting little x
and then Y squared--
AUDIENCE: Sum over u and big Y.
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
So sum of codegree
of two vertices in Y,
so Y, Y prime, and Y codegree
of little y, little y prime.
And likewise, the
next expression
can be written as the sum of
the degrees of vertices in Y.
And the third term,
I leave unchanged.
So now we've gotten rid
of these funny expressions
where it's just degree
from the vertex to a set.
And we could do this because
of this relaxation up here.
So that was the point.
We had to use this
relaxation so that we
get these codegree terms.
But now, because you
have the codegree terms
and we assume the
codegree hypothesis,
we obtain that
this sum is roughly
what you expect as in a
random case, because all
the individual deviations do
not add up to more than little
o n cubed.
That codegree sum
is what you expect.
And the next term,
the sum of degrees,
is also, by what we did
up there, what you expect.
And finally, the third term.
And as earlier, if you
did everything correctly,
everything should cancel.
And they do.
And so what you get at the
end is little o of n squared.
This completes
this fourth cycle.
Any questions so far?
So we're missing
one more condition,
and that's the
eigenvalue condition.
So far, everything had to do
with counting various things.
So what does eigenvalue
have to do with anything?
So the eigenvalue
condition is actually
a particularly important one.
And we'll see more of
this in the next lecture.
But let me first show you
the equivalent implications.
So what we'll show is that
the eigenvalue condition is
equivalent to the C4 condition.
So that's the goal.
So I'll show equivalence
between EIG and C4.
So first, it implies a C4
condition, because up to--
so instead of
counting C4s, which
is a little bit actually not--
it's a bit annoying
to do actual C4s.
Just like earlier, we want to
consider homomorphic copies,
which are also labeled walks,
so closed walks of length 4.
So up to a cubic error,
the number of labeled C4s
is given by the number of
closed walks of length 4, which
is equal to the trace of the 4th
power of the adjacency matrix
of this graph.
And the next thing
is super important.
So the next thing is sometimes
called a trace method.
One important way that the
eigenvalue, so the spectrum
of a graph or matrix, relates to
other combinatorial quantities
is via this trace.
So we know that the
trace of the 4th power
is equal to the fourth
moment of the eigenvalues.
So if you haven't seen
a proof of this before,
I encourage you to go
home and think about it.
So this is an important
identity, of course.
4 can be replaced by
any number up here.
And now you have the
eigenvalue condition.
So I can estimate the sum.
There's a principle
term-- namely, lambda 1.
So that's the big term.
Everything else is small.
And the smallness is supposed
to capture pseudorandomness.
But the big term, you have
to analyze separately.
OK, so let me write
it out like that.
So the big term, you know that
it is p to the 4 n to the 4
plus little o of n to the 4.
OK.
So next thing is what to
do with the little terms.
So we want to show that
the contribution in total
is not too big.
So what can we do?
Well, let me first
try something.
So first, well, you see
that each one of these guys
is not too big.
So maybe let's bound each
one of them by little o of n
raised to 4.
But then there are
n of them, so you
have to multiply by an extra n.
And that's too much.
That's not good enough.
So you cannot individually
bound each one of them.
And this is a novice mistake.
This is something
that we actually
will see this type
of calculation
later on in the term when
we discuss Roth's theorem.
But you're not supposed to
bound these terms individually.
The better way to do
this or the correct way
to do this is to pull
out just a couple--
some, but not all--
of these factors.
So it is upper bounded
by-- you take max of--
in this case, you can
take out one or two.
But you take out,
let's say, two factors.
And then you leave the
remaining sum intact.
In fact, I can even put lambda
1 back into the remaining sum.
So that is true.
So what I've written down is
just true as an inequality.
And now I apply the
hypothesis on the sizes
of the other lambdas.
So the one I pulled out
is little o of n squared.
And now what's the second sum?
That sum is the
trace of a squared,
which is just twice the
number of edges of the graph.
So that's also at
most n squared.
So combining everything,
you have the desired bound
on the C4 count.
Of course, this gives
you an upper bound.
But we also did a
calculation before the break
that shows you that the C4 bound
has a lower bound, as well.
So really, having the
correct eigenvalue--
actually, no, this
already shows you
that the C4 bound is
correct in both directions,
because this is the main term.
And then everything
else is small.
OK.
The final implication is
C4 implies eigenvalue.
For this one, I need to
explore the following important
property of the top eigenvalue.
So there's something
that we also
saw last time, which
is the interpretation
of the top eigenvalue of
a matrix interpreted as--
so this is sometimes called
the Courant-Fischer criterion.
Or actually, this is a special
case of Courant-Fischer.
This is a basic
linear algebra fact.
If you are not familiar with
it, I recommend looking it up.
The top eigenvalue of a matrix,
of a real, symmetric matrix,
is characterized by the maximum
value of this quadratic form.
Let's say if x is
a non-zero vector.
So in particular, if I set
x to be a specific vector,
I can lower bound lambda 1.
So if we set this boldface 1
to be the all-one vector in R
raised to the number
of vertices of G,
then the lambda 1 of
the graph is at least
this quantity over here.
The numerator and denominators
are all easy things
to evaluate.
The numerator is just
twice the number of edges,
because you are summing up
all the entries of the matrix.
And the denominator is just n.
So the top eigenvalue
is at least roughly pn.
So what about the
other eigenvalues?
Well, the other
eigenvalues, I can again
refer back to this
moment formula relating
the trace and closed walks.
It is at most the
trace of the 4th power
minus the top eigenvalue
raised to the 4th power.
It's the sum of the
other eigenvalue
raised to the 4th power.
And 4 here, we're using the 4.
It's an even number, right?
So you have this over here.
So having a C4 hypothesis and
also knowing what lambda 1 is
allows you to control
the other lambdas.
See, lambda 1 cannot be
much greater than pn.
Also comes out of
the same calculation.
Yep.
AUDIENCE: So [INAUDIBLE]
number 1 equal to [INAUDIBLE]??
PROFESSOR: Yeah, thank you.
Yeah, so there's a correction.
So lambda 1 is--
so in other words,
the little o is always
respect to the constant density.
OK, yeah.
Question.
AUDIENCE: You said in the
eigenvalue implies C4,
you somewhere also used the
lower bound to be proved
[INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: OK.
So the question is in
eigenvalue implies C4,
it says something
about the lower bound.
So I'm not saying that.
So as written over here,
this is what we have proved.
But when you think about the
pseudorandomness condition
for C4, it shouldn't be just
that the number of C4 count
is at most something.
It should be that
it equals to that,
which would be implied by
the C4 condition itself,
because we know, always, it
is the case that a C4 count is
at least what it is
compared to the random case.
So just one more thing I
said was that lambda 1,
you also know that it is at
most pn plus little n, because--
OK.
Yeah.
So this finishes the proof of
the Chung-Graham-Wilson theorem
on quasi-random graphs.
We stated all of
these hypotheses,
and they are all
equivalent to each other.
And I want to emphasize, again,
the most surprising one is
that C4 implies everything
else, that a fairly seemingly
weak condition, this just
having the correct number
of copies of labeled C4s,
is enough to guarantee
all of these other much more
complicated looking conditions.
And in particular, just
having the C4 count correct
implies that the counts of
every other graph H is correct.
Now, one thing I
want to stress is
that the Chung-Graham-Wilson
theorem is really
about dense graphs.
And by dense, here,
I mean p constant.
Of course, the theorem
as stated is true
if you let p equal to 0.
So there, I said p
strictly between 0 and 1.
But it is also OK if
you let p be equal to 0.
You don't get such interesting
theorems, but it is still true.
But for sparse graphs, what
you really want to care about
is approximations of the
correct order of magnitude.
So what I mean is that
you can write down
some sparse analogs
for p going to 0,
so p as a function of n going
to 0 as n goes to infinity.
So let me just write down
a couple of examples,
but I won't do all of them.
You can imagine what
they should look like.
So DISC should say this
quantity over here.
And the discrepancy
condition is little o
of pn squared, because
pn squared is the edge
density overall.
So that's the quantity you
should compare against and not
n squared.
If you're comparing
n squared, you're
cheating, because n
squared is much bigger
than the actual edge density.
Likewise, the number of
labeled copies of H is--
I want to put the
little o 1 plus little
in front, so instead of
plus little o of n to the H
at the end.
So you understand
the difference.
So for sparse, this is
the correct normalization
that you should have,
when p is allowed
to go to 0 as a function of n.
And you can write down all
of these conditions, right?
I'm not saying
there's a theorem.
You can write out
all these conditions.
And you can ask, is there also
some notion of equivalence?
So are these
corresponding conditions
also equivalent to each other?
And the answer is emphatically
no, absolutely not.
So all of these equivalents
fail for sparse.
Some of them are still true.
Some of the easier
ones that we did--
for example, the two versions
of DISC are equivalent.
That's still OK.
And some of these calculations
involving Cauchy-Schwarz
are mostly still OK.
But the one that really
fails is the counting lemma.
And let me explain
why with an example.
So I want to give you an
example of a graph which
looks pseudorandom in the
sense of DISC but has no,
let's say, C3 count.
It also has no C4
count, but it has no--
has the clean, correct
number of triangles.
So what's this example?
So let p be some number which
is little o of 1 over root n
so some decaying
quantity with n.
And let's consider Gnp.
Well, how many triangles
do we expect in Gnp?
So let's think of p as just
slightly below 1 over root n.
So the number of triangles
in Gnp in expectation is--
so that's the expected number.
And you should expect
the actual number
to be roughly around that.
But on the other hand,
the number of edges
is also expected to
be this quantity here.
And you expect that the
actual number of edges
to be very close to it.
But p is chosen so that
the number of triangles
is significantly smaller
than the number of edges,
so asymptotically smaller, fewer
copies of triangles than edges.
So what we can do
now is remove an edge
from each copy of a
triangle in this Gnp.
We removed a tiny
fraction of edges,
because the number of
triangles is much less
than the number of edges.
We removed a tiny
fraction of edges.
And as a result, we do
not change the discrepancy
condition up to a small error.
So the discrepancy
condition still holds.
However, the graph
has no more triangles.
So you have this pseudorandom
graph in one sense--
namely, of having
a discrepancy--
but fails to be pseudorandom
in a different sense--
namely, it has no triangles.
Yep.
AUDIENCE: Do the
conditions C4 and codegree
also hold here-- so the issue
being from DISC to count?
PROFESSOR: Question,
do the conditions C4
and codegree still hold here?
Basically, downstream is
OK, but upstream is not.
So we can go from C4
to codegree to DISC.
But you can't go upward.
And understanding how to rectify
the situation, perhaps adding
additional hypotheses
to make this true so
that you could have counting
lemmas for triangles
and other graphs
and sparser graphs,
that's an important topic.
And this is something
that I'll discuss
at greater length
in not next lecture,
but the one after that.
And this is, in fact, related
to the Green-Tao theorem,
which allows you to approve
Szemerédi's theorem among
the primes.
The primes contain arbitrarily
long arithmetic progressions,
because the primes
are also a sparse set.
So it has density going to 0.
It's density decaying,
like, 1 over log n,
according to prime
number theorem.
But you want to do
regularity method.
So you have to face
this kind of issues.
So we'll discuss that more at
length in a couple of lectures.
But for now, just a warning
that everything here
is really about dense graphs.
The next thing I
want to discuss is
an elaboration of what happens
to these eigenvalue conditions.
So for dense graphs,
in some sense,
everything's very clear
from this theorem.
Once you have this, theorem,
they're all equivalent.
You can go back and forth.
And you lose a little bit
of epsilon here and there,
but everything is
more or less the same.
But if you go to sparser
world, then you really
need to be much more careful.
And we need to think
about other tools.
And so the remainder
of today, I want
to just discuss one fairly
simple but powerful tool
relating eigenvalues on one hand
and the discrepancy condition
on the other hand.
All right.
So you can go from
eigenvalue to discrepancy
by going down this chain.
But actually, there's
a much quicker route.
And this is known as the
expander mixing lemma.
For simplicity and really will
make our life much simpler,
we're only going to
consider d-regular graphs.
So here, d-regular means
every vertex is degree d.
Same word, but different
meaning from epsilon regular.
And unfortunately, that's
just the way it is.
So d regular, and we're
going to have n vertices.
And the adjacency matrix has
eigenvalues lambda 1, lambda 2,
and so on, arranged
in decreasing order.
Let me write lambda
as the maximum
in absolute value
of the eigenvalues
except for the top one.
In particular, this is
either the absolute value
of the second one
or the last one.
As I mentioned earlier,
the top eigenvalue
is necessarily d, because
you have all-ones vector
as an eigenvector.
So the expander mixing lemma
says that if I look at two
vertex subsets, the number of
edges between them compared
to what you would expect
in a random case--
so just like in the
disc setting, but here,
the correct density I
should put is d over n--
this quantity is upper bounded
by lambda times the root
of the product of x and y.
So in particular,
if this lambda--
so everything except for the
top eigenvalue-- is small,
then this discrepancy
should be small.
And you can verify with what
we did, that it's consistent,
what we just did.
All right.
So let's prove the
expander mixing
lemma, which is pretty simple
given what we've discussed
so far, relating-- so there was
this spectral characterization
up there of the top eigenvalue.
So we can let J be
the all-ones matrix.
So let J be the all-ones matrix.
And we know that
the all-ones vector
is an eigenvector of the
adjacency matrix of G
with eigenvalue d.
So the eigendecomposition of
J is also the all-ones vector
and its complement.
So we now see that A
sub G minus d over nJ
has the same eigenvectors as AG.
So you can choose the
eigenvectors for that.
It's the same set
of eigenvectors.
Of course, we consider
this quantity here,
because this is exactly
the quantity that comes up
in this expression
once we hit it
by characteristic vectors of
subsets from left and right.
All right.
So what are the eigenvalues?
So A previously had eigenvalues
lambda 1 through lambda n.
But now the top one
gets chopped down to 0.
So you can check
this explicitly.
So you can check this
explicitly by checking
that if you take this
matrix multiplied
by the all-ones
vector, you get 0.
And if you have a
eigenvector-eigenvalue pair,
then hitting this by
any of the other ones
gets you the same as
in A, because you have
this orthogonality condition.
All the other eigenvectors
are orthogonal
to the all-ones vector.
All right.
So now we apply the
Courant-Fischer criteria,
which tells us that the
number in this discrepancy
quantity, which we can write
in terms of this matrix,
it is upper bounded by
the product of the length
of these two vectors,
x and y, multiplied
by the spectral norm.
So I'm not quite using
the version up there,
but I'm using the
spectral norm version,
which we discussed last time.
It's essentially
the one up there,
but you allow not just
single x but x and y.
And that corresponds to
the largest eigenvalue
in absolute value,
which we see that.
It's at most lambda.
So at most lambda times size
of x, size of y square root.
And that finishes the proof
of the expander mixing lemma.
So the moral here is that,
just like what we saw earlier
in the dense case but for
any parameters-- so here,
it's a very clean statement.
You can even have done
the degree graphs.
d could be a constant.
If lambda is small
compared to d, then
you have this
discrepancy condition.
And the reason why this is
called an expander mixing lemma
is that there's this
notion of expanders,
which is not quite the same
but very intimately related
to pseudorandom graphs.
So one property of pseudorandom
graphs that is quite useful--
in particular, in
computer science--
is that if you take a
small subset of vertices,
it has lots of neighbors.
So the graph is now
somehow clustered
into a few local pieces.
So there's lots of expansion.
And that's something
that you can guarantee
using the expander mixing lemma,
that you have lots of-- you
take a small subset of vertices.
You can expand outward.
So graphs with that
specific property,
taking a small
subset of vertices
always gets you
lots of neighbors,
are called expander graphs.
And these graphs play an
important role, in particular,
in computer science in
designing algorithms and proving
complexity results and
so on but also play
important roles in graph
theory and combinatorics.
Well, next time, we'll address
a few questions which are along
the lines of, one, how small can
lambda be as a function of d?
So here is this.
If lambda's small compared to d,
then you have this discrepancy.
But if d is, let's
say, a million,
how small can lambda be?
That's one question.
Another question is,
considering everything
that we've said so far,
what can we say about,
let's say, the
relationship between some
of these conditions
for sparse graphs
but that are somewhat special--
for example, kd graphs
or vertex-transitive graphs?
And it turns out some
of these relations
are also equivalent
to each other.